I admit I have very little idea of
what's going on in which Tim battle
majors story
no such luck my lord but hey I can
summon ice and fire to my palms and
fling around the elements like a demigod
never has magic felt as powerful as it
does in Lich them where it's free from
the constraints of mana bars and long
cooldowns I enjoy lich tombs magical
combat so much in fact that I suspect
it'll spoil other games spell casting
for me I call down flames from above
corrupted magical flakes billow forth
from my fingers and infect my demonic
enemies and the great targeting assist
lets me show off my impressive wizardry
even when my opponents and I are
constantly on the move you start with
only fire and ice at your disposal
though your options grow as you progress
through the two sizable levels that
Lynch them currently offers you equip
three different magical sigils each of
which gives you three different skills a
targeted spell an area of effect attack
and a shield that allows you to counter
offensive moves as well as to mitigate
damage you can flip between different
sigils at will and during battle the air
is awash with magic as you strafe around
avoiding oncoming spells and slinging
icy projectiles which Tim is gorgeous
though it's amazing looks aren't enough
to mask the game's repetition each
encounter feels more or less like the
last and the pace rarely wavers the
spell casting feels amazing but I longed
for something a bit more maybe a
set-piece show of destruction or an
environmental puzzle to solve
the bosses provide a bit of tempo change
but my general tactics rarely wavered
nevertheless Lich Tim is poised for
greatness with its spell creation
utility leading the charge as foes fall
they leave behind various spell
components that you can synthesize into
more effective materials and then
combine to make more powerful spells the
types of spells never change but they
gain new characteristics and statistics
for example simple fireballs can turn
into flaming death orbs with a chance to
stagger targets and set them on fire for
a period of
early on I paid close attention to how I
combines components but in time the
differences between similar spells were
to minut for me to care i enjoy the
freedom of the spell casting but there
comes a moment when the difference is
between two spells of the same variety
and strengths don't seem particularly
meaningful there's no doubt however that
lists embattlement ails the basics never
have I felt more like a commanding
sorcerer than I do here if developers
avian can give its game coherence
storytelling and diversify the
unwavering pace lich 'dom would become
truly awesome
Oh
[Music]